la dépendance un colloque est organisé
ce matin sur ce thème au conseil
économique social et environnemental
colloque conclu par nicolas sarkozy qui
va annoncer les grands enjeux de la
réforme on écoute tout de suite son
discours en direct c'est nous équilibres
économiques et sociaux
nous pouvons toujours refusé de regarder
cet avenir en face mais cet avenir va
finir par devenir notre présent
s'agissant de l'allongement de la durée
de vie et du vieillissement
il est écrit d'avancé et ses
conséquences aussi en vérité nous
n'avons pas le choix nous devons choisir
maintenant quelle place nous allons
faire dans notre société
à l'âge et au grand âge ce problème est
devant nous non pas loin mais tout près
nous ne pouvons plus attendre plus nous
attendrons plus ce sera difficile car on
ne fait pas une telle évolution ni en
quelques journées en quelques mois
ni même en quelques années il faut que
les mentalités les comportements les
institutions s'adapte à la réalité
sociale et démographique qui jour après
jour s'impose à nous je dirais
inexorablement il faut que les systèmes
de financement non en charge
nous ne pouvons plus attendre peut-être
même avant nous collectivement déjà trop
attendu
nous avons progressivement réformer le
système de retraite nous les avons
sauvées de la faillite à laquelle le
choc démographique les condamnés à plus
ou moins brève échéance
nous avons sauvé la répartition une
principe de la solidarité entre les
générations qui est au coeur de notre
pacte social
nous l'avons fait en choisissant de
travailler davantage plutôt qu'en
augmentant les impôts les charges qui
auraient principalement pesé sur le
travail encourager les délocalisations
détruit les emplois réduit le pouvoir
d'achat faire converger les régimes
spéciaux allonger la durée de cotisation
relever l'âge de la retraite à taux
plein ce fut je le sais demandez à ceux
qui travaillent des efforts
supplémentaires mais nous n'avions pas
le choix
fallait-il attendre de se trouver dans
la situation où nous n'aurions plus à
choisir qu'entre la fin de la
répartition et la réduction des pensions
de retraite
je me suis refusé c'était difficile mais
alors que la crise creuse est
dramatiquement nos déficits
c'était mon devoir de prendre des
décisions qui auraient été encore plus
difficile et aurait demandé encore plus
de sacrifices si elle avait été différée
à l'horizon 2020 l'équilibré financier
de nos retraites et assuré
mais sur la dépendance qui est une autre
conséquences de l'allongement de la
durée de la vie et du vieillissement
notre société jeudi notre société parce
que cela nous concerne tous a pris du
retard
ce qui me conseille d'attendre ce qu'ils
me disent que ce n'est pas le moment
d'ouvrir un tel chantier de réforme
devrait se pencher sur les difficultés
inextricables et si douloureuse dans
lesquelles sont plongés tant de familles
qui se chauffent confronté à la perte
d'autonomie de leurs proches
affaibli par l'âge et ne pouvant plus
affronter seul la vie quotidienne
et que dire de ceux qui n'ont pas de
famille que personne ne soutient n
accompagne et qu'on oublie dans leur
terrible solitude
que dire de la souffrance de celui que
l'on arrache de sa maison où ils
n'aspirent qu'à finir ses jours parce
que personne ne veut au fond se
compliquer la vie
pour l'aider à s'y maintenir
nous connaissons tous ses difficultés
ses souffrances ce désarroi et nous
savons tous que la montée de la
dépendance n'en est qu'à ses débuts que
le problème ne va cesser de grandir et
que si nous ne mettons pas maintenant
les moyens d'y répondre
alors il y aura davantage de peine de
souffrance et de désarroi ce qui est en
jeu ce n'est pas seulement d'ordre
matériel dans ce financier ce qui est en
jeu c'est l'idée que nous nous faisons
de notre société
devrais-je même dire de notre
civilisation ce qui est en jeu est
humain est affectif et morale c'est dans
le sort qu'elle réserve dans la place
qu'elle donne dans la considération
qu'elle porte aux plus humbles aux plus
vulnérables aux plus fragiles au plus
innocents des siens que se mesure la
valeur morale et humaine d'une société
c'est sans doute dans les regards du
handicap et du malade dans le regard du
vieillard ou de l'enfant
que celui le bonheur de vivre dans une
société c'était un sel et celle de la
vie de l'importance et du respect qu'on
lui accorde
et c'est nous-mêmes de notre propre
histoire de notre propre avenir
au fond de notre propre dignité dont il
s'agit parce que ces malades si
handicapés
ces enfants ces vieillards sont nos
parents ces vieillards meilleur jour si
tout se passe bien ça sera nous
je n'ai pas le sentiment de parler des
autres en parlant de cela c'est de nous
dont il s'agit
quelle estime pourrions-nous avoir de
nous même si nous étions incapables de
traiter dignement nos parents
incapable de les aider à vivre
pleinement jusqu'à la fin de leurs jours
à vivre
pas seulement à survivre comment
pourrions nous alors quand à notre tour
nous serons devenus fragiles vulnérables
comment à ce moment là après avoir
oublié nos parents nous pourrions
demander l'aide et l'attention de nos
enfants c'est ça qui est en cause
ce qu'ils auraient abandonné leurs
parents ne seraient pas les mieux placés
pour demander à leur tour à leurs
enfants de ne pas faire à eux ceux qui
ne sont pas hésité ne riez pas hésité de
faire à leurs parents donc nous ne
pouvons pas laisser les choses en l'état
et nous ne les laisserons pas en état
donc je n'attendrai pas
attendre encore serait une faute morale
impardonnable
ce serait refusé de regarder la réalité
en face se serait refusé d'assumer mes
responsabilités
pourquoi refuser d'assumer ses
responsabilités parce que c'est
difficile
parce que l'année prochaine il y aura
des élections présidentielles
mais qui pourrait comprendre que l'on ne
s'attaque pas un problème grave parce
qu'il est difficile
tu pourrais accepter que l'on s'arrête
d'agir de réformer un an et demi avant
la fin d'un quinquennat
qui peut croire que j'ai été élu pour
cela qui peut penser que c'est ce que
les français attendent et qui peut
imaginer que les français préfèrent
l'immobilisme au risque d'une réforme
dont ils sont au fond domaine absolument
convaincus qu'elle est nécessaire
mais naturellement une réforme de cette
ampleur qui concerne des sujets qui
touchent chacun si profondément ne peut
pas être une réforme venu dans la
manière dont nous abordons le problème
de la dépendance notre société n'est pas
la faire d'une catégorie sociale ou
d'une génération
c'est une question qui nous est posée à
tous la réflexion doit être collective
et leurs réponses aussi si la sécurité
sociale a pu exister c'est parce que les
français se la sont appropriée c'est
parce que pour chaque français et elle
est la propriété de tous
eh bien je voudrais que la dépendance
fassent l'objet de la même appropriation
par les français qu'elle soit
l'expression de la même solidarité que
les retraits la maladie la famille le
chômage
c'est assez dire qu'il ne s'agit pas à
mes yeux d'une réforme comme une autre
mais qu'il s'agit d'ajouter une nouvelle
dimension à notre pacte social
un tel projet ne peut pas s'inscrire
dans le débat politique ordinaire
il exige de la part de chacun un effort
sur lui-même pour s'élever au dessus des
clivages partisans idéologiques et
laisser sa conscience son coeur sa
raison indiqué la voix de l'intérêt
général comme le firent jadis les
auteurs du programme du conseil national
de la résistance et les bâtisseurs de la
sécurité sociale
c'est à cette exigence intellectuelle et
morale que nous appelle le souvenir de
ce qu'ils ont accompli et l'ampleur de
la tâche à laquelle nous nous appelons
aujourd'hui
c'est un chapelle des échanges des
discussions des débats parce qu'il
s'agit d'aborder l'un des problèmes les
plus sensibles qui se posent à notre
société celle respect que nous devons à
ce clavier prouve à ce que laisserait
dans la difficulté dans la paix notre
imprévoyance collectif
si nous n'arrivions pas à dégager un
consensus suffisant
gardons donc ce sujet à l'abri des
polémiques
nous ne travaillons pas pour les 15 mois
qui viennent nous travaillons pour le
demi siècle à venir dire que le débat
qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui n'est pas
politique ne serait pas exact
car ce n'est pas un débat technique un
débat d'experts ça débat de société
et quoi de plus politique un débat de
société mais c'est un débat autour de ce
qui nous rassemble de ce qui fonde notre
rapport à l'autre et non ce qui nous
oppose est ce qui nous divise
nous parlons de ceux au nom de quoi nous
vivons ensemble et qui fait que le nous
reconnaissons tous dans l'idée du bien
commun encore faut-il élever
suffisamment le débat non pour le bras
c'est que des idées générales loin des
réalités humaines et sociales
mais pour embrasser ce problème dans
toutes ses dimensions
je veux dire par là comprenons la
question de la dépendance par le seul
biais de sa prise en charge et son
financement
on dénature est la question de la
dépendance serait refaire l'erreur qui
fut longtemps fait de ne voir le
problème de la vieillesse qu'à travers
celui de la retraite sans s'occuper de
la participation des retraités à la vie
sociale
le problème de la maladie qu'à travers
celui de l'assurance maladie sans se
préoccuper ni de la santé publique ni de
la place du malade dans la société ou
encore celui du handicap sous le seul
angle de la compensation financière sans
se soucier de l'insertion sociale des
handicapés
ce n'est que vers les années 80 que les
choses ont commencé à changer lentement
trop lentement
songez qu'il a fallu attendre 2005 pour
que la loi impose que les établissements
recevant du public soit accessible à
tous songez qu'il a fallu attendre 2009
pour qu'un retraité qui bénéficient
d'une retraite à taux plein puisse
cumuler sans restriction sa pension de
retraite avec un revenu d'activité
songez qu'il a fallu attendre 2007 pour
que commence à être amélioré l'accès à
l'emprunt pour des malades qui jusque là
sans trouver exclue ou soumis à des
conditions exorbitantes
non vous êtes malade vous n'allez pas en
plus demandé à vous le g
ce taux raisonnables
la rapidité de l'évolution démographique
nous oblige à ne pas perdre de temps et
à traiter d'emblée la question de la
dépendance dans le cadre des politiques
de santé publique de prévention et de
recherche qui se verraient accorder
enfin l'importance qu'elle mérite
pluriel je pense bien sûr recherche sur
les maladies du grand âge alzheimer qui
ne se limite pas la recherche en
laboratoire la gérontologie qui devrait
enfin conquérir ses lettres de noblesse
parce qu'elle a beaucoup à nous
apprendre
la dépendance n'est pas une fatalité je
veux dire on peut la repousser on peut
éviter qu'à fragilité d'une personne
âgée dont la tension baisse ou qu'ils se
fatiguent plus vite ne la conduisent
inexorablement vers la dépendance en
aménageant mieux les logements en
prévoyant un accès de proximité un
médecin en prenant certaines précautions
en apprenant certaines règles de
comportement nous savons que nous
pourrions prévenir l'apparition de
beaucoup de situations de dépendance ou
éviter d entrée en établissement les
personnes âgées elles-mêmes joue un rôle
essentiel pour prévenir leur perte
d'autonomie en entretenant leur mémoire
en étant active en participant à la vie
de la cité
les proches bien sûr sont les premiers à
les aider à les maintenir dans une vie
sociale active mais la collectivité a
son rôle à jouer
des actions de prévention doivent être
développées il nous faut donc aborder le
problème sous l'angle plus large de la
place
la place du grand âge dans notre société
je dis bien dans la société et non pas à
l'écart de celle ci après une trop
longue prise de conscience une grande
mutation est en train de s'opérer
quant à notre façon de traiter la
vieillesse nous commençons à associer
les personnes âgées à la vie sociale
nous construisons des maisons de
retraite qui ne sont plus des lieux
j'emploie le mot des lieux de relégation
comme si le grand âge devait être
éloigné de la vue de la vue de ceux qui
vivent une vie active
ces lieux de pique des lieux de vie et
on ne voit plus ses grands dortoirs de
les aligner sans aucune intimité sans
aucune vie sociale
aujourd'hui les personnes âgées peuvent
compter sur un personnel soignant mieux
formés la prise en charge des résidents
est en progrès on ne se contente pas de
les soigner de les héberger et de leur
proposer des activités pour passer le
temps beaucoup d'établissements
construisent de véritable projet de vie
auquel les pensionnaires participe
pleinement avec un investissement
exceptionnel des personnels soignants et
non soignants des directeurs
d'établissement mais aussi des
professionnels de santé libéraux
il nous faut inscrire le traitement de
la dépendance dans ce grand mouvement de
réinsertion de la vieillesse dans la vie
sociale il ne s'agit pas que les plus
âgés dans les facultés décline puis
seulement survivre tant bien que mal
surtout sans déranger personne
il s'agit de tout faire pour que leur
vie soit une vraie vie le plus longtemps
possible pour quand même affaiblie
diminué privé de tout ou partie de leur
autonomie
ils puissent encore éprouvé à cette joie
de vivre pour que le bonheur d'être là
l'emportent sur la lassitude le
sentiment d'être de trop
et même la tente du nord vécu comme une
délivrance d'une existence qui n'a plus
de sens ou sociétés qui traitent comme
cela c'est vieux est une société qui n'a
aucune morale et il ne respecte pas la
dignité humaine on peut être dépendant
on peut avoir perdu sur l'autonomie
et vouloir qu'on respecte sa dignité
parce qu'on est jusqu'au bout une
personne humaine
alors de quoi ont-ils d'abord besoin
même ceux qui ont tout oublié
même ceux qui sont revenus comme des
enfants même ceux qui sont déjà ailleurs
ils ont besoin d'amour ils ont besoin
qu'on les aime alors vous me direz nous
sommes bien loin de ce qu une politique
peut faire l'amour ne se décrète pas le
bonheur non plus mais rien n'empêche d'y
penser lorsqu'on choisit un peu une
politique et on ne fera pas la même
politique si l'on considère la
dépendance comme un problème à résoudre
par la seule logique administrative et
bureaucratique aussi on la considère
d'abord comme un bouleversement de notre
rapport à la vie
on ne traite pas l'enfant handicapé de
la même manière si l'on ne voit à
travers son handicap qu'un problème
pratique à résoudre ou si on se le
représente je veux dire cet enfant
handicapé comme une source
d'enrichissement humain pour les autres
enfants à travers quoi à travers
l'apprentissage de la différence
alors nous devons faire attention à ne
pas construire une société où tous les
liens de nature affective ou morale
serait rompu ou le choeur par tous
s'effacerait devant le droit de
répandant partout la terrible fatalité
de la solitude la personne âgée
dépendante
je la firme doit pouvoir rester le plus
longtemps possible dans son
environnement familier est un axe
tel doit le plus longtemps possible
conservé des liens familiaux affectifs
les relations de voisinage qui
nourrissent sa vie intérieure et sa vie
sociale
le maintien le plus longtemps possible à
domicile l'encouragement solidarité
familiale aux solidarités de proximité
doivent être regardées comme des
priorités absolues dans une politique à
l'égard des personnes âgées dépendantes
qui considèrent leur présence dans la
société comme une source d
enrichissement humain et qui repose sur
la conviction que le sentiment d'être
aimé et peut-être le plus important que
l'on puisse faire à l'endroit de ceux
qui nous ont tant donné
il s'agit pas de cacher le grand h il
s'agit de le réinsérer dans la vie
sociale et de le voir comme un
enrichissement
alors si nous en sommes tous convaincus
nous ne devons pas seulement réfléchir à
la prise en charge de la dépendance par
la société mais à la prise en charge de
la dépendance dans la société
c'est pas qu'une question de sémantique
question absolument essentiel s'agit pas
de faire prendre en charge par la
société il s'agit d'organiser la
dépendance dans la société
pendant les moyens modernes
télésurveillance télémédecine domotique
la révolution numérique nous permet de
l'envisager sur une échelle et pour des
degrés dépendance pour lesquels
s'étaient jusqu'à présent impensable et
à des coûts moindres que l'hébergement
dans des maisons de retraite
médicalisées
mais les équipements les moyens
techniques aussi performant soit il ne
sont rien sans une prise de conscience
une mise à jour de la responsabilité de
chacun je souhaite que la question de la
responsabilité des familles sont au
coeur de la réflexion parce qu'il est au
coeur de la solidarité entre les
générations et de la transmission
parce que la piété filiale et la
reconnaissance de tout ce que l'on n'a
reçu d'amour et de sacrifices et que
cette dette
en quelque sorte cette reconnaissance
est sans doute ce qui donne le plus de
sens à la vie qui s'achève oui je
l'affirmé on a tous une dette
à l'endroit de ceux qui nous ont donné
la vie et qui nous ont accompagnés sur
le chemin de cette vie
il ya un continuum
ça s'appelle les valeurs d'une société
et on est responsable vis-à-vis de cette
tête
la société est là pour accompagner les
familles les soutenir les aider les
soulager mais j'affirme que la société
n'est pas là pour remplacer les familles
un autre soit politique très fort comme
mon esprit la société ne remplacera
jamais la famille elle doit aider la
famille doit soutenir la famille mais ne
peut pas la remplacer
la société est là pour permettre aux
familles de faire vivre les valeurs de
partage qui unissent les générations
entre elles et non pour leur signifier
qu'elle n'aurait plus aucun rôle à jouer
parce que ces valeurs serait dépassé
merci ces valeurs sont dépassées que
transmet trion nous à nos enfants
donc ces valeurs ne sont pas dépassés et
le débat sur la dépendance et les
décisions que nous allons prendre sont
l'occasion de parler de ses valeurs et
de les faire triompher
chacun sent bien que la dépendance n'est
pas qu'un problème financier
c'est aussi une question morale qui nous
touche au plus profond de nous-mêmes pop
il s'agit pas simplement de savoir de
combien ça coûte
mais quelle place nous donnons
naturellement les familles ne peuvent
pas tout faire aux prises avec des
difficultés innombrables les familles
doivent pourra s'appuyer sur les
collectivités les associations sur une
main-d'oeuvre qualifiée capable de
pratiquer des soins de faire face aux
besoins de la vie quotidienne
formé à l'hygiène à la sécurité à
l'ecoute au dialogue à l'accompagnement
psychologique
c'est un domaine où l'expérience et les
qualités humaines sont précieuses comme
la gérontologie qui doit être reconnue
comme une spécialité médicale à part
entière aussi valorisante aussi
prestigieuses que les autres les emplois
qui accompagne le grand âge hugues
aufray être considérés comme des petits
boulots des boulots au rabais que l'on
fait faute de mieux
sans en avoir le goût sans y être
préparée avec le sentiment qu'ils ne s'y
attache aucune reconnaissance sociale
il va falloir relever le statut social à
la mesure de leur utilité de leur
nécessité
il faut les professionnaliser valider
les acquis d'expérience améliorer les
conditions de travail et de rémunération
ne pas les laisser dans la précarité
avec le sentiment d'une absence totale
de perspective nous avons besoin de ces
professionnels car ce sont des
professionnels
souvenons nous que rendre la demande
solvable ne suffit pas il va falloir
aussi structurer l'offre et la qualité
de l'offre dépendra de la qualité des
hommes et des femmes qui voudront bien
se dévouer pour les autres se mettent au
service des autres non pas seulement
dans une relation exclusive en marchande
mais dans une relation aussi humaine il
va falloir créer les conditions pour que
l'engagement de ces hommes et ces femmes
soit un choix un choix de vie car tout
ce qui ne sera pas fait avec un peu
d'eux de coeur sera une cause
supplémentaire de peine et de souffrance
mais si nous laissons famille toute la
charge financière de la dépendance
nous pouvons espérer atteindre aucun des
objectifs que nous dit pourtant notre
raison ouvrir le débat sur la dépendance
c'est d'ouvrir la voie à une profonde
transformation sociale s'est engagé un
changement en profondeur de nos rapports
sociaux de notre rapport à la vie de
notre rapport à l'avenir ce n'est pas
seulement équilibrer les comptes
alors si la problématique de la
dépendance dépasse largement la
problématique financière
si elle ne peut pas être enfermé dans la
seule logique comptable la question de
son financement n'est pas moins
incontournable
eq exprime-t-elle d'autres en vérité
cette question du financement que la
nécessité du partage pas seulement le
partage avec ceux que nous aimons avec
ceux auxquels nous devons d'être ce que
nous sommes mais aussi le partage entre
le présent et l'avenir
entre ce à quoi nous sommes prêts à
renoncer aujourd'hui pour être couvert
demain à quoi sommes-nous prêts à
demain une question absolument essentiel
incontournable inévitable
car ce que nous verserons pour nos
parents nos enfants à leur tour le ver
seront pour nous dans le continuum dont
je parlais il ya quelques instants
alors qu'aujourd'hui vous connaissez les
chiffres ils sont effrayants une
personne âgée sur cinq est en mesure de
financer sur ses seuls revenus son
hébergement en maison de retraite
une personne âgée sur cinq
nous ne pouvons pas laisser les familles
seules face à la montée de la dépendance
pour y faire face
ces 25 milliards d'argent public qui
seront mobilisés cette année c'est plus
de la moitié de ce que nous dépensons
pour notre politique familiale
ces trois fois ce que nous dépensons
pour les accidents du travail et les
maladies professionnelles
ces 25 milliards emprunte une multitude
de cadeaux dont les principaux sont
l'assurance maladie et les départements
alors quand on sait que ces dépenses ont
augmenté au rythme de 1 milliard par an
au cours des quatre dernières années
on mesure l'inquiétude des gestionnaires
de ces organismes est celle des pouvoirs
publics confronté aux déficits abyssaux
creusé par la crise financière alors que
chacun fait tout ce qu'il faut pour
maîtriser ses dépenses alors que pour la
première fois depuis 1997
l'objectif des dépenses d'assurance
maladie a été tenue en 2010 au prix
d'efforts importants alors que beaucoup
de départements se débat dans des
difficultés financières de plus en plus
grande
on ne peut pas imaginer faire financer
par l'endettement
c'est à dire par nos déficits l'effort
supplémentaire qu'il s'avérera
nécessaire de consentir dans les années
à venir en faveur de la prise en charge
de la dépendance
je refuse cette fois
et je la ferme
tu veux dire celle du déficit et de
l'endettement nous devrons là comme
ailleurs dépenser mieux mais nous
devrons aussi dépenser plus il nous faut
donc réfléchir à un nouveau financement
nous devons chercher ensemble la
meilleure solution à la fois du point de
vue de la justice et de l'économie
taxer davantage le travail et en
augmenter le coût ne conduira qu'à une
délocalisation encore plus importante de
nos emplois
si un nombre toujours plus réduits
d'actifs doit prendre en charge un
nombre toujours plus grand dit d'actifs
c'est tout notre système de protection
sociale tout notre modèle social qui
explosera
je vois bien les revendications de ton
actif retravaillé - moins autant dans la
semaine - autant dans la journée et
moins longtemps dans la vie et dans le
même temps de plus en plus d'inactifs
dont il faut financer la protection
sociale
comment cela peut-il fonctionner ça ne
peut pas fonctionner je ferme également
cette fois
aussi je demande à chacun d'entre vous
d'examiner toutes les autres options
possibles
de n'écarter d'emblée aucune solution y
compris celle de l'assurance pour des a
priori idéologiques l'idéologie n'a rien
à faire dans une affaire de cette
importance et de cette humanité
quand nos finances publiques sont dans
la situation où elles sont quand le
travail est à ce point taxé quand cinq
millions de français ont déjà souscrit
une assurance dépendance est il
raisonnable de ne pas s'interroger sur
le rôle que peuvent jouer les mutuelles
les compagnies d'assurances et les
organismes de prévoyance
ne fermons pas le débat avant de l'avoir
ouvert cherchons de façon pragmatique la
solution la plus efficace
réfléchissons aux règles qui dans tous
les cas feront prévaloir les principes
de justice auquel nous sommes tous
attachés pour la prise en charge de la
dépendance il nous faut sans doute
inventer autre chose que le modèle
traditionnel de couverture des risques
par la sécurité sociale
je n'ai pas pour autant parler par
hasard d'un cinquième risque mais pas ce
que je souhaitais que la couverture de
ce risque
quel que soit le mode de financement
obéissent elle aussi au principe
d'universalité et de paritarisme qui
gouvernent les quatre branches de la
sécurité sociale
personne ne devrait être tenu à l'écart
de cette couverture ou pénaliser ni à
cause de son âge ni à cause de son état
de santé ni à cause de son niveau de
revenu l'universalité implique l'absence
totale de discrimination je ne
transigerai pas sur ce principe que la
loi devra garantir
de la même manière il va de soi que pour
moi les partenaires sociaux ne saurait
être exclue du pilotage de la
surveillance et du contrôle du système
de prise en charge de la dépendance quel
qu'il soit il faudra y associer d'autres
acteurs comme les départements dont le
rôle est majeur avec la dépendance c'est
donc une nouvelle forme de paritarisme
qui doit voir le jour une nouvelle forme
de paritarisme que nous allons inventer
je le dis aussi pour rassurer ceux qui
auraient un doute je n'ai pas
l'intention d'utiliser la dépendance
pour privatiser insidieusement
l'assurance maladie je n'ai pas non plus
l'intention de diluer le handicap dans
la dépendance
la situation des handicapés dans la
société est une priorité le restera
j'avais d'ailleurs promis que
l'allocation adulte handicapé serait
revalorisé de 25% durant mon mandat
cette promesse est scrupuleusement tenus
je me suis de longue date engagé sur la
question de la scolarisation des enfants
handicapés
elle sera lors du jour de la prochaine
conférence nationale du handicap en juin
prochain si l'impératif d'insertion dans
la société est le même pour le malade le
handicapé est la personne que la
condamne à la dépendance la dépendance
pose un problème bien différent de la
maladie ou du handicap qui doit donc
être abordée en tant que tel nous
n'avancerons pas dans la confusion
nous n'avancerons que dans la clarté en
faisant la part des choses avec des
réponses et des financements adaptés
pour chaque cas c'est une ligne de
conduite dont nous ne devons pas dévié
si nous voulons que le dispositif que
nous allons mettre en place soit lisible
soit compréhensible soit gérable que
chacun soit bien convaincu
il n'ya dans ma volonté d'ouvrir le
dossier de la dépendance
aucune intention cachée aucune arrière
pensée idéologique ou électorale qu'elle
pourrait de pétrel d'ailleurs cette
pensée le débat qui s'ouvre a donc
toutes les raisons d'être apaisé est
tout entier consacré à la recherche d'un
large consensus
nous avons six mois devant nous c'est
con mais nous partons pas de rien c'est
un sujet auquel les parlementaires les
conseils généraux le monde associatif
les partenaires sociaux les experts ont
déjà beaucoup réfléchi je pense aux
peintures et au rapport d'alain vasselle
et valérie rosso-debord que je remercie
qui vous ont présenté ce matin les
résultats du travail approfondi qu'ils
ont effectué les quatre groupes de
travail sont mises en place par roselyne
bachelot et marie-anne montchamp je leur
fais toute confiance
réunissent l'ensemble des compétences et
je remercie
roselyne comme ariane de leur courage et
de leur volonté
elles savent qu'elles ont une obligation
de résultat comme chacun d'entre nous
les débats qui sont organisées au niveau
régional et clairons utilement les
travaux des groupes et notre réflexion
commune ils permettront de bien serrer
les attentes de nos concitoyens
plusieurs institutions apporteront leur
éclairage a commencé monsieur président
par le conseil économique social et
environnemental
puis après la réflexion l'échangé
viendra l'heure de la prise de décision
et de la responsabilité
roger souvent répété ce mot de
responsabilité mais vous savez les
français ne nous demande pas de réussir
surtout et ça bien que c'est difficile
de diriger un pays il demande que les
responsables que nous sommes assument
leurs responsabilités qu'ils fassent
face quand ça marche comme concernant je
suis pas
assumer sa responsabilité devait être la
priorité de chaque responsable c'est ça
qu'attendent de nous les français à la
lumière de vos travaux le gouvernement
élaborera son projet avant l'été
prochain en vue d'un examen par le
parlement à l'automne
et si à la fin de cette année mes chers
compatriotes nous pouvons dire à nos
enfants vos retraites seront payées
votre dépendance sera prise en charge
alors nous aurons changé le rapport que
notre jeunesse entretien avec l'avenir
elle regardera notre jeunesse - l'avenir
comme une menace et davantage l'avenir
comme une promesse
si nous pouvons nous dire que ce que
nous avons fait à l'humour un jour dans
le regard perdu de celui qui a tant
besoin des autres pour vivre
doucement doucement la fin de son
existence une petite étincelle de
bonheur et d'espérance alors nous avons
fait de notre mieux et nous pourrons
être fiers de ce que nous aurons
accompli ensemble
j'ai conscience que je vous demande est
difficile mais vous devez avoir
conscience que nous n'avons pas le choix
ça fait trop d'années que la france
attend
nous sommes là pour résoudre les
problèmes les vrais problèmes défendent
les solidarités
les vraies solidarités a lancé tout de
suite
six mois pour en parler quelques
semaines pour prendre la décision et la
postérité jugera si en somme nous avons
été à la hauteur de nos responsabilités
ou pas je remercie votre attention
nicolas sarkozy qui a donc lancé l'une
des réformes phares de son quinquennat
est celle de la dépendance une réforme
qu'il a bien sûr longuement défendu
nous ne pouvons pas laisser les choses
en l'état se serait refusé d'assumer ses
responsabilités mais il a précisé qu'il
s'agissait d'un débat de société sans
les arrière pensées électorales il est
bien sûr longuement revenu sur la
question du financement de cette réforme
de la dépendance
rappelons que les familles ne peuvent
pas tout assumer
il a annoncé que 25 milliards d'euros
seraient mobilisés pour l'année pour
l'année à venir mais qu'il fallait
réfléchir un nouveau mode de financement
en n'écartant aucune solution y compris
celle de l'assurance privée
une des propositions du rapport
sénatorial de philippe marini et d'alain
vasselle rapport rendu la semaine
dernière
et puis à noter qu'un débat sera
organisé au sénat la semaine prochaine
mardi prochain le 15 février un débat
que vous pourrez bien sûr suivre en
direct sur public sénat est très bonne
journée à tous
publicsenat.fr devenir le portail